et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
donc laurent jacot vélib on joue aussi
beaucoup d'être avec nos porte parole du
rassemblement national vous présidez
également le groupe rassemblement
national dans la région grand est la
région couverte par les journaux du
groupe ebra bon jean fabrice vce à rouen
jour oriane bonjour monsieur g co
présentée ce matin puisque notre
interview et en partenariat avec la
presse quotidienne régionale le roi
jacques aubé lyon va commencer
évidemment par les annonces hier soir de
jean castex ça y est on connaît la
mesure du gouvernement pour aider les
français à faire face à la hausse des
prix ce sera donc une indemnité
inflation c'est comme ça que l'ap les
gens qu'à 500 euros pour tous les
français qui gagnent moins de 2000 euros
net par mois ça concerne 38 millions de
personnes selon le premier ministre
c'est la bonne mesure pour vous non
écoutez c'est du bricolage d'abord parce
que ça rate sa cible imaginé un couple
foyer où l'un gagne 6000 euros nets
l'hôte gagne 1800 euros net et bien
celui qui touche 1800 honnête aura la
prime de fin d'année donc vous voyez
bien que c'est pas forcément très juste
on peut d'ailleurs ne pas consommer
d'essence ne pas avoir de voiture et
avoir cette prime et puis surtout
fondamentalement ça ne règle pas le
problème c'est à dire que l'essence
aujourd'hui est très cher pourquoi parce
que deux tiers du prix est constitué de
taxes c'est donc sur ces taxes qu'il
faut agir pour avoir une solution de
long terme permettre aux français de
retrouver du pouvoir d'achat c'est ce
que propose marine le pen en passant la
tva sur les produits énergétiques de 20%
à 5 et demi pour cent c'est le taux
affectés aux produits de première
nécessité de l'énergie c'est la première
des choses que vous l'avez entendu hier
le premier ministre a dit la baisse des
taxes n'est pas la bonne solution ça
concerne tout le monde de manière
indifférenciée et surtout on ne sait pas
si ça va vraiment aux consommateurs
voulant temps des fêtes à riom je
l'entends c'est d'ailleurs une bonne
nouvelle parce que monsieur castex et
une boussole qui indique la mauvaise
direction donc quand il n'est pas
d'accord avec une mesure c'est un
indicateur qui allait probablement bonne
vous savez si on baisse la tva sur
l'énergie d'abord des français vont
avoir plus de pouvoir d'achat vont
consommer plus et donc ça va amener de
l'argent à l'économie si par exemple un
artisan qui doit faire le plein de sa
camionnette pour travailler aujourd'hui
voit les coûts augmenter de 25% en et
bien si jamais on réduit cette charge ce
sont ses bénéfices qui vont augmenter et
donc il investira soit dans du personnel
soit dans des machines soit pour avoir
de nouveaux marchés et donc ce sera bon
pour l'économie c'est une économie
vertueuse le premier ministre un très
vieux schémas en tête le schéma de la
taxe où on ponctionne les français on
ponctionne les entreprises en permanence
il ne se rend pas compte que ça
affaiblit le dynamisme économique du
pays laurent jacobellis vous auriez été
favorable à ne pas désolidarisée cette
prime à l'intérieur d'un couple d'un
foyer je suis bien ce que vous venez
mais nous n'aurions pas choisi avec
marine le pen ce système de primes dès
le départ donc c'est difficile de
rentrer dedans dans ce scénario il ya
vous relevez injuste est-ce que c'est
individuel et non foyer conjugal je me
rends tous temps et se sont souvent en
c1 l'effet des femmes qui perçoivent
moins dans un couple je me rends compte
juste que cette mesure elle est mal
fagotée d'ailleurs il suffisait de
revoir le premier ministre hier sur le
plateau d'une chaîne concurrente il
était extrêmement mal à l'aise lui même
semblait ne pas bien connaître son
dossier ni les tenants et les
aboutissants je vais vous dire quelque
chose par exemple qui va payer cette
prime d'abord ce sont les entreprises en
fin d'année qui un jour seront
remboursés par l'état d'ailleurs je ne
sais pas si vous avez la nouvelle moi je
ne sais pas quand elles seront
remboursées au après la crise du coc
vides beaucoup de tpe pme ont des
problèmes de trésorerie et donc on leur
demande un effort de trésorerie
supplémentaire vous voyez bien que cette
mesure elle n'a pas été réfléchie elle a
été écrite sur le coin d'une table je
vais vous dire c'est pas une mesure
contre l'inflation c'est une mesure pour
les élections le président de la
république et le premier ministre vont
faire un chèque en espérant se redonner
une image un peu plus généreuse pour les
élections à venir mais c'est pas une
mesure de fond de jean castex a dit
effectivement qui préciserait les
modalités de versement de cette prime
dans les prochains jours sur la tva
cesser la hausse de la tva sur les
carburants qui va permettre de financer
une partie de cette prime est que si on
baisse la tva comme vous le souhaitez ça
va pas du coup au contraire faire un
cercle vertueux mais plutôt un cercle
vicieux il ya moins de tva on peut moins
versées aux français mais si l inverse
parce que moins de tva sur les énergies
c'est plus de pouvoir d'achat pour les
français les français qui ont plus de
pouvoir d'achat qu'est ce qu'ils vont
faire ils vont se remettre à consommer
ce qu'ils ont abandonnée beaucoup de
français se prive de viande à partir de
la deuxième semaine du mois ce prix de
s'acheter des vêtements se prive de
partir en week-end tout simplement parce
qu'il n'y a plus d'argent dans les
caisses très vite baisser la tva surtout
pas surtout pas surtout sur l'énergie
sur l'énergie un exemple l'énergie a
tellement flambé que lorsque l'on se
chauffe au gaz on payait pour un foyer
en moyenne 800 euros par an aujourd'hui
c'est 1250 euros vous imaginez bien que
pour beaucoup de foyers cela devient
insupportable
mais là où il faut aller plus loin c'est
un véritable choc de pouvoir d'achat de
paris mme le pen veut créer pas
seulement avec cette tva réduite sur les
énergies mais par exemple en supprimant
la redevance télévision en privatisant
de télé en privatisant les chaînes de
télévision et de radio publiques en
faisant diminuer le coût des péages
renationaliser les les concessions mais
aussi en créant une part plein pour les
impôts à partir du deuxième enfant ce
sont des mesures extrêmement concrètes
qui va améliorer le quotidien des
français et donc relancer la machine
économique et qui vont coûter combien
sur l'essence par une phase sur les
énergies par exemple c'est une mesure
qui coûte 12 milliards voilà donc on l'a
chiffrée un peu plus que la mesure
annoncée par jean castex bien sûr
beaucoup plus allait être là mais alors
beaucoup moins beaucoup moins que tous
les chèques faits emmanuel macron en ce
moment d'ailleurs qu'il va laisser à son
prédécesseur à la future présidente de
la république mais c'est cet argent là
il est réinvesti dans l'économie et puis
les sources d'économies budgétaires
elles existent 15 à 45 milliards de
fraude sociale entre 50 et 100 milliards
d'évasion fiscale bref l'argent existe
l'énergie est ce qu'il faut par exemple
baisser le nombre de fonctionnaires
comme le proposent certains candidats
c'est ça il faut travailler sur la
question des retraites est ce que vous
êtes toujours sur la retraite à 60 ans
c'est la course à l'échalote on a six
millions et demi de chômeurs certains
candidats ont comme seul objectif
d'ancrer entre 100 et 300 milles
supplémentaires la situation hongroise
de fonctionnaires pour y écouter nous
verrons au cas par cas pas de poste
inutile bien sûr mais enfin c'est pas
une idéologie de supprimer des postes de
fonctionnaires par principe on n'est pas
dans une situation de plein emploi où on
peut supprimer des postes on est au
contraire dans une situation on a six
millions et demi de chômeurs et puis la
retraite vous savez il faut dire les
choses aux français à partir de 57 ans
la majorité des français ne travaillent
plus parce qu'ils sont au chômage les
entreprises ne veulent plus engagée des
gens de plus de 57 ans et donc il touche
soit le chômage soit le rsa en attendant
la retraite est donc aujourd'hui ça veut
dire qu'ils touchent le chômage et le
rsa pendant six ans si vous des calames
on sait combien de français ça concerne
un français de plus de 57 ans sur deux
voilà donc c'est énorme et bien si vous
décaler la retraite encore plus vous
allez puiser dans les caisses sociales
et améliorer les caisses de retraite
vous allez prendre d'une poche pour
aller mettre dans l'autre tout ça c'est
de l'idéologie d'ailleurs emmanuel
macron la dila estime que les français
ne travaillent pas assez vous savez il
ya cette espèce de fantasme d'une forme
d'élite entre guillemets qui pensent
bien au chaud dans les ministères que de
travail pendant que les français vont à
la pêche c'est pas ça la réalité les
français travaillent dur et le problème
c'est que même s'ils travaillent dur ils
n'ont plus assez à la fin du mois pour
travailler à la durée du temps de
travail ou pas mais là encore non
aujourd'hui c'est 35 heures bon est-ce
qu'on va 0,35 à brest mais on permet aux
entreprises d'assouplir par des accords
de branche si besoin une dernière
question concernant l'énergie vous étiez
opposé à la fermeture de la centrale de
fessenheim tout à fait dans le conteste
est ce que vous estimez cette crise
remet en perspective la question du
carburant il prix du carburant des
carburants c'est quoi le bon plan en
termes d'énergie en france pour rester
favorable au nucléaire oui et on
investit dans rien d'autre non mais bien
sûr le nucléaire aujourd'hui au moment
où on se parle et l'énergie la plus
propre et la moins chère et qui nous
permet le plus d'indépendance
énergétique en france c'est une folie de
devoir détricoter ce que nous a légué le
général de gaulle en matière énergétique
et la fermeture de fessenheim est un non
sens c'est un anachronisme au moment où
on veut une énergie plus propre je pense
que les gouvernements qui se sont
succédé ont céder au diktat de
l'écologie politique et ils ont été dans
le marketing politique notamment en
investissant dans les éoliennes or les
éoliennes ça marche 25% du temps ce qui
veut dire que ça ne marche pas 75% du
temps et que donc il faut combler ce
manque énergétique vous êtes fermement
opposés aux éoliennes clairement mais
pas par idéologie tout simplement parce
que ça ne marche pas ça ne marche pas
75% du temps ça
détruit les paysages il faut le dire
aussi ça fait baisser la valeur
immobilière des biens de nombreux
français qui sont incapables ensuite de
vendre leur maison ça tue en plus un
certain nombre d'oiseaux bref sur plein
de domaines c'est une c'est un fantasme
en fait éoliennes c'était peut-être on
investit pas encore il faut investir
dans l'énergie propre mais
pas forcément les éoliennes n'est pas
loin l'hydrogène on a encore beaucoup à
faire sur le nucléaire il y aller
nouvelle génération de centrales qu'il
faut mettre au point il ya les minières
pour les minicentrales ça c'est la bonne
réponse pour vous en tout cas le
souhaitent que le président de la
république ait changé de pied sur le
nucléaire est une bonne nouvelle alors
combien de temps ça va durer vous savez
les convictions des manuels macron dur -
le moins longtemps que qu'une saison
mais on verra bien sur le nucléaire pour
qu'on prenne comprennent bien votre
position il fallait pas fermer
fessenheim et on a bien compris mais ça
veut dire que dans le mix énergétique à
l'heure actuelle le nucléaire c'est 70 %
de notre énergie faut aller à combien on
reste à 70 % on essaye de faire baisser
la part à 50% comme l'envisagent non
mais je ne comprends pas cette volonté
de faire baisser la part non reste à 70
% mais oui tant que cette énergie est
démontré comme étant la plus décarbonés
étant la moins chère pour les français
et nous permettant de ne pas dépendre
d'autres pays c'est à dire d'être
autonome eh bien je ne comprends pas
cette volonté de détricoter ce qui
marche c'est quand même fou pour une
fois que nous sommes encore en pointe
dans un domaine qu'on nous admirent dans
le monde entier pour cette cette
technologie nous qu'est ce qu'on fait on
dit là bas on va arrêter c'est un non
sens alors ça ce sont les points
positifs du nucléaire il ya aussi une
question de vétusté des centrales je
l'intéressais notamment capitanio c'est
une question d'enrichissement des
déchets de sûreté de nos centrales cas
ce qu'on fait mais on continue comme
avant on a toujours fait en accélérant
s'il le faut les normes de sécurité bien
évidemment il faut pas lésiner sur ces
questions mais que je sache je ne ferme
pas des réacteurs ont investi ont à
nouveau pour essayer de les réacteurs
notamment nouvelle génération qui
permettront de limiter voire de réduire
à zéro les déchets enfouis tout ça il
faut travailler là dessus sont
d'ailleurs deux formidables ressources
de recherche et développement ça devrait
être un axe stratégique d'un état
stratège il se trouve qu'on a un état
aujourd'hui un gouvernement qui réagit
au jour le jour et qui réagit sous la
pression médiatique un dernier mot sur
ces questions puisque en plus de cette
prime inflation de cette indemnité
inflation jean castex a annoncé hier que
le prix du gaz serait bloquée alors plus
seulement jusqu'en avril comme il
l'avait annoncé il ya quelques semaines
mais jusqu'à la fin du mois de décembre
2022 ça c'est une bonne nouvelle pour
vous oui ça permet d'attendre mais une
fois encore c'est pas une mesure de fond
c'est bien le problème avec ce
gouvernement c'est qu'ils ont senti que
les élections arrivent et donc emmanuel
macron et jean castex se promène de
ville en ville de congrès
socioprofessionnelle en congrès
socioprofessionnelles avec le chèque ils
font des chèques qui d'ailleurs sur
l'électorat l'histoire c'est une manière
de répondre à l'inquiétude des français
compris qu'ils ont du mal à payer vous
avez vu il ya des gilet jaune oui on
commence à apparaître à nouveau sur les
ronds-points ça vous inquiète mais moi
ça ne m'inquiète pas je comprends très
bien leur leur présence sur les ronds
points puisque rien n'a changé les jets
les jaunes ils veulent quoi ils veulent
plus de pouvoir d'achat c'est à dire que
on peut travailler en france et
bénéficier de son salaire c'est la
moindre des choses ils veulent du
respect ils veulent de la démocratie
emmanuel macron leur a redonné le
pouvoir d'achat baisse 2 français sur 3
sans que leur pouvoir d'achat baisser
donc car ils se sentent qui n'est pas
forcément le cas selon les chiffres du
gouvernement c'est pas garde algérienne
en moyenne mais les 10% les plus riches
peut effectivement se sont encore
enrichi mais les français les plus
modestes ne le sentent bien que le
pouvoir d'achat diminue donc
deuxièmement ils veulent le respect or
ils ont un président de la république
qui les insultent tous les quatre matins
et ils veulent plus de démocratie
c'est-à-dire la proportionnelle le
référendum d'initiative citoyenne et
qu'est ce qu'ils ont en retour le vote
du pass sanitaire et de la fin du secret
médical la nuit la nuit à quelques
députés sans prévenir personne donc vous
voyez bien que les motifs de
mécontentement sont toujours les mêmes
mais justement va parler de sa place
sanitaires l'assemblée nationale a voté
sa prolongation vous êtes favorable bien
sûr que non on a l'impression que le coc
vide rend fou en tout cas rend fou
ministre de la santé cette volonté de
continuer avec le pass sanitaires alors
qu'aujourd'hui
plus rien ne justifie qu'il soit en
place c'est une volonté idéologique je
ne vois pas autre chose il faudra qu'il
nous explique ce qu'il a dans la tête
parce qu'aujourd'hui on sait qu on
inciterait encore les français sert
vacciner pour vous ces palabres majeur
75% des français aujourd'hui sont
vaccinés ce qui est beaucoup et on voit
bien que ça n'a pas un effet incroyable
sur la propagation du virus le vaccin
aujourd'hui il est extrêmement utile
évidemment parce qu'il permet d'éviter
les formes graves mais il n'évite pas à
complètement la transmission et à partir
du moment où on as fait ce constat le
pass sanitaire ne sert à rien nous
sommes tous les trois dans ses pièces
peut-être avons-nous notre pass
sanitaires rien ne dit que l'on ne se
contaminent rappaz donc il faut arrêter
avec cette espèce de pensée magique
comme si le pass sanitaire était un
bouclier contre la maladie c'est faux
c'est un bouclier contre les libertés
vous avez le vôtre c'est vous qui
l'évoqué foot nous sommes trois
peut-être flamande où vous avez l'autre
j'ai mon pass sanitaires à jour où j'ai
le droit d'être là est ce que vous êtes
favorable à aller plus loin l'obligation
vaccinale c'est ce que propose notamment
les socialistes pensaient la solution
était évidemment le point commun entre
les manuels macron et c'est les
socialistes dès qu'on parle restrictions
de libertés tout le monde lève le doigt
non il faut arrêter il faut supprimer le
pass sanitaires et il faut laisser la
liberté vaccinale aux français vous
savez aujourd'hui le vrai problème c'est
qu'il existe à peu près entre hal et 8
et 10 % des français les plus
vulnérables et les plus potentiellement
capable d'attraper le vide qui ne sont
pas vaccinés et bien tous les efforts
doivent être mis sur ces français là et
arrêter de vouloir par exemple vacciner
coûte que coûte les gamins au prix
d'ailleurs de la levée vous vous tenez
bien du secret médical qui a été voté en
première lecture à l'assemblée nationale
ce qui est un coup de canif incroyable
dans les règles de libertés publiques de
notre république voilà ce à quoi est
prêt ce gouvernement il faut que ça
cesse l'autre sujet tout autre sujet
dont on va parler c'est la pologne la
pologne qui est au menu du sommet
européen qui se tient en ce moment même
à bruxelles relations compliquées entre
l'union européenne et la pologne depuis
des années en raison de réformes
judiciaires dans le pays et tensions
accrues depuis la décision du tribunal
constitutionnel pour le nez de faire
primer le droit national sur le droit
européen alors hier le chef du
gouvernement polonais ne s'est dit prêt
au dialogue il a rencontré emmanuel
macron on peut rester dans cet entre
deux mais je crois qu'il faut laisser
les polonais tranquille bien évidemment
que le droit national polonais doit
primer sur un éventuel droit européen en
pologne et d'ailleurs il faut que ce
soit la même chose en france ce sont les
français qui doivent décider de leur
sort et non pas un commissaire européen
que personne n'aura élu ou un président
de l'union européenne que personne
n'aura élus vous savez marine le pen sur
son dans son référendum sur
l'immigration elle veut mettre une
clause sur une espèce de boucliers
constitutionnel c'est-à-dire que la
france sera protégée j'allais dire de
loi internationale et la priorité sera
sur les lois françaises lorsqu'elle
s'oppose mais c'est la moindre des
choses ils sont faits clarifier les
choses à ce qu'on peut rester dans
l'union européenne en remettant en cause
les règles de l'union européenne mais il
n'est pas question de remettre en cause
les règles de l'union européenne le
problème il est à linverse c'est que
l'union européenne n'a pas à se mêler
des lois des états c'est clair les
polonais sont maîtres chez eux ils ont
élu un gouvernement aux abois appliquer
un programme il faut les laisser
tranquilles quand j'entends monsieur
thierry breton proche du gouvernement
commissaire européen dire que finalement
la france serait comparable un des états
des états unis et devrait simplement
appliquer le droit européen et se taire
c'est un non sens historique et c'est
vraiment grave la primauté du droit mais
nous ne sommes pas un état fédéré
l'union européenne n'est pas un état
fédéré la souveraineté des peuples la
souveraineté des pays et est à l'origine
de la construction européenne une brique
essentielle dans la construction qui se
passe en pologne pour vous en tant qu'
on doit dire souverainisme nationaliste
d'ailleurs je ne sais pas où comme vous
voulez moi je me qualifierais de
souverainistes ce qui se passe employons
actuellement vous conforte dans votre
position en tout cas à dire c'est une
question de la liberté de la presse de
l'indépendance des juges
je parle là de la souveraineté de l'état
ça ne veut pas dire que nous allons
faire exactement la même politique que
la pologne en revanche de quel côté caen
la liberté et l'indépendance
vous êtes de quel je vais me permettre
de terminer mon propos ce qui est
important c'est que lorsque le 24 avril
marine le pen deviendra présidente de la
république elle puisse appliquer la
politique pour laquelle les français
louis et que à chaque fois qu'elle
prendra une mesure soit par référendum
notamment sur l'immigration soit sur un
certain nombre de questions le droit
français qui sera votée qui suivra le
processus normal par les deux assemblées
la navette entre les deux que ces lois
là soient appliquées et que aucune loi
internationale nous vienne polluer la
volonté des français quant à la pologne
je ne suis pas polonais je suis
incapable et je vous le dis franchement
de décrypter la société polonaise mais
faisons confiance aux polonais pour
savoir ce qui est bon chez eux je crois
qu'ils font confiance à leur
gouvernement les résultats électoraux le
montre laissons les tranquilles vous
savez cette union européenne qui met en
faillite la grèce et qui vient donner
des leçons de démocratie à la pologne
elle serait mieux de balayer devant sa
porte alors pour vous marine le pen sera
élu le 24 avril en même temps c'est
logique vous êtes son porte parole le
porte parole du rassemblement salle sauf
que les sondages ils se suivent et ne se
ressemblent à dynamique elle n'est pas
du côté de marine le pen aller du côté
d'eric zemmour ça vous inquiète non ça
ne m'inquiète pas d'abord vous n'avez
pas vu je croit le dernier sondage qui
donne marine le pen entre 18 et 20% éric
guimond à 12% donc ça vient contredire
cette dynamique vous savez on est en
début de campagne on est en précampagne
donc évidemment il ya un effet nouveauté
eric zemmour et je comprends bien que
pour la presse pour les médias
télévisuels et même pour les sondeurs il
y ait une espèce d'attraction une
curiosité qui fait que les antennes sont
largement ouvertes exemple il est en
train de ringardiser marine le pen dont
je crois pas je vous dis à marine le pen
n'a jamais été aussi moderne la preuve
toutes nos mesures seront reprises par
tout le monde quand j'entends monsieur
ciotti parler de priorité nationale 2 je
lis les aloses les allocations sociales
pour les étrangers pendant les premières
années de leur venue en france c'est mot
pour mot le programme de marine le pen
eric zemmour ne fait pas d'autres
constats que ce que font le
rassemblement national et avant le front
national depuis 40 ans donc aujourd'hui
tout le monde puis notre programme et je
vais vous dire on est content de se
faire piller pourquoi parce que ça
prouve que ce programme est bon et si on
nous le dit c'est parce que les français
sont d'accord avec nous vous savez c'est
facile de parler d'immigration 80% des
français nous donne raison sur la
question c'était plus difficile il y a
dix ans comme nous le faisions déjà nous
avons l'expérience nous avons les bonnes
mesures notre programme est prêt à être
appliquée à j + 1 marine le pen était
1024 dé la mission fut bien sûr le fond
vous êtes sur la même ligne qu'eric
zemmour pas du tout d'abord ce serait
plutôt à lui d'être sur notre ligne
parce que et c'est un nouvel entrant il
fait un certain nombre de postes deux
constats sur la société française
notamment sur l'immigration sur claude
est partagé bien sûr sur la civilisation
et les risques mais quand monsieur
zemmour dit que nous sommes entrés en
guerre civile eh bien nous ne partageons
pas ce constat nous nous pensons que il
faut ramener la paix sociale la paix
civile en france et qu'on peut le faire
avec des mesures de bon sens sans créer
plus de divisions dans le pays emmanuel
macron à fracturer le pays il a mis la
police contre les gilet jaune elle est
vaccinée contre les non vaccinés mais
quand vous les choix de civilisation de
ce jeudi marine le pen cette élection
c'est ce sera un choix d'exécution c'est
bien qu'il ya deux civilisations qui
s'opposent pour vous il va falloir
choisir entre 2 c à l'opposition c'est
qu'il ya un risque pour notre
civilisation
oui quand on voit que dans certaines
villes de banlieue parisienne trois
quarts des enfants qui naissent naissent
de parents étrangers oui bien sûr ce
n'est pas normal quand on voit qu'un
certain nombre de fillettes portent le
voile pour aller à l'école bien sûr que
ce n'est pas normal quand on voit que
des jeunes adolescents ce supposé
homosexuels se font tabasser en question
en raison de leur sexualité bien sûr que
ce n'est pas normal il y a des valeurs
et notamment
valeurs républicaines des valeurs
d'égalité hommes femmes que nous devons
défendre face à un islamisme il faut le
dire face à une volonté d'imposer des
règles théologique à la place des règles
démocratiques
eh bien ça il faut lutter et lutter
contre ça ça veut dire fermer les
mosquées radical renvoyer chez eux les
prêcheurs de haine et puis plus
généralement arrêtés les pompes
aspirantes de l'immigration et arrêter
l'immigration face à ce vent porteur
pour eric zemmour même si le dernier
sans dot l'indiqué vous relativisez un
petit peu cela est ce que marine le pen
et vous même vous ne craignez pas au
moment donné une fuite à la fois une
partie de votre électorat mais aussi de
vos cadres et de vos militants 2 marine
le pen est vert eric zemmour alors ça
c'est un serpent nicolas dupont aignan
vous connaissez bien connu ce phénomène
unique les premières victimes d'ailleurs
de ce duel c'est vrai la différence
c'est que nicolas dupont aignan n'a
jamais été en position de gagner face à
emmanuel macron marine le pen est en
position de gagner et je crois
qu'aujourd'hui tous les souverainistes
ou tous les nationaux selon le vocable
que vous choisirez doivent savoir que la
seule candidate capable demain
d'apporter l'alternance patriotes
l'alternance française dont nous avons
besoin c'est marine le pen le programme
de marine le pen il est simple c'est
rendre leur pays et leur argent aux
français eh bien tous ceux qui se
reconnaissent dans cette phrase doivent
nous rejoindre et aujourd'hui on le voit
bien dans les fameux sondages que vous
évoquez et que j'aime pas trop évoquer
mais je vous suis là dessus au deuxième
tour la seule en capacité aujourd'hui
c'est marine le pen donc c'est un choix
raisonnable disney
tout en n'étant pas qualifiés après le
premier quand même à vous le
reconnaîtrez un mot juste puisque vous
parlez de nicolas dupont aignan vous
avez passé un accord avec l'ue en 2010
est est ce que vous pourriez passer un
tel accord avec l'examen d'une verrons
bien nous verrons bien quelles sont ses
propositions aujourd'hui on ne les
connaît pas et c'est pas exclu mais
marine le pen a dit qu elle tendrait la
main à tous les patriotes kalos qu'elle
ferait un gouvernement d'union nationale
tous ceux qui voudront travailler avec
nous dans la droite file du programme
qui aura fait élire marine le pen nous
travaillons avec eux bien évidemment ces
gens sont initiés de vous avez proposé à
nicolette du point et demi avec le
premier ministre la peine vous pourriez
en faire de même avec les règlements
écoute il faudrait le demander à la
candidate marine le pen ils ne vont pas
en porte parole merci mais je ne connais
pas aujourd'hui son programme donc c'est
un peu compliqué de vous le dire je sais
simplement qu'il a fait un certain
nombre de constats que nous partageons
il le fait parfois de manière un peu
brutale un peu radical qui ne correspond
pas à notre vision d'une nation apaisée
donc il y a du travail à faire mais
évidemment nous avons comme on dit à
l'école un tronc commun et donc ça
permet de travailler ensemble
éventuellement merci beaucoup merci
laurent jats commercial ammar était
notre invité ce matin merci fabrique
[Musique]